federal prosecutors say two men are
facing charges for allegedly using
encrypted messaging apps to plan a
series of attacks to avenge former
president trump's defeat
in the 2020 election authorities say the
men armed with machine guns and bombs
hoped to inspire a movement and reached
out to anti-government militia groups
for support
this as new reporting reveals just how
rocky those final days were
inside the trump white house and just
how close we may have come to war with
iran
chris van cleave reports
a new report reveals former president
trump's top general was actively working
to stop him from striking iran in the
final days of his presidency
if you do this you're going to have a
expletive war general mark milley would
say according to the article
the same concern held by house speaker
nancy pelosi who told 60 minutes
she called the chairman of the joint
chiefs personally i have sought
information from those who are in a
position to know that there are
protections against this dangerous
president initiating
any military hostilities or
something worse than that before general
milley left a january third meeting the
president told him his january sixth
rally was
going to be a big deal and asked you're
ready for that right
the new yorker reports it was the last
time the two would speak
newly revealed secret service documents
show the agency underestimated the
threat on january 6
repeatedly reporting there is no
indication of civil disobedience
the agency had given the go-ahead for
mike pence to travel to the capitol on
the 6th
and later had to rush him off the senate
floor his protective detail
implored the vice president to leave the
building but he refused according to a
new book on the final year of the trump
presidency
telling his lead agent i'm not getting
in the car tim if i get in that vehicle
you guys are taking off i'm not getting
in the car
the book says pence then called the
pentagon with this order
get troops here get them here now we've
got to get the congress to do its
business
the former president was critical of
general milly in a statement this week
saying millie is a better politician
than he is a general
the house select committee investigating
january 6 has scheduled its first
hearing for later this month
for cbs this morning saturday chris van
cleave washington